is that monday jun 15 that 930am will be
the first of the big three console
manufacturers taken to the stage
Microsoft going to show off all their
hot first party video games maybe show
us some new technology maybe show us a
box with the xbox one which doesn't have
some of their old technology in it we're
going to talk about all that right now
Justin hey welcome banner or Chris
waters Microsoft remember that III did
it a couple years ago with a settle that
stuff and they spent the past wall just
just feeling like we out yet just just
didn't take backsies take backsies and
what I guys looking forward to this year
first off I guess with games that they
are going to talk about let's talk about
halo 5 to Chris water ah hail RDF yeah
we've had the multiplayer bit earlier
this year they've been teasing these
super cryptic story trailers and we're
definitely going to get a huge showcase
of that my I feel like I'm going to feel
awkward when I watch it when the 343
industries folks walk out talking about
halo what are they going to give a tip
of the hat to the ongoing or to the
master chief collection situation it'll
probably just be some some line they'll
move on to the Guardians but yeah like
this is interesting cuz they're setting
a master chief to be kind of the not a
hero or maybe these and he's like not
just the shining bastion of alien killer
II that he has always been I am I'm
interested to see if you know we know
are going to have their the campaign we
know they're going to have the
multiplayer sort of competitive eSports
focus that we've seen in the beta is
there going to be a middle ground
somewhere is there going to be something
separate cooperatively is there going to
be some kind of Spartan Ops thing is
there going to be some sort of third
pillar of halo 4 that we see at the
press conference yeah guess well to find
out kevin van orange are you excited for
Rise of the Planet of the tomb Raider's
is that what the name of it is what on
and hope and they're going to rebrand it
this is a timed exclusive we keep it
getting mentioned and reminded of rather
for the xbox one ave tomb raider the
reboot what a fantastic little reboot
that was a yes I don't totally well yeah
I mean it'll take a look at this
everybody in the office knows I have
this thing about snow yeah alright so
bathroom with your credit card just chop
chop chop yeah that's that's me all
right every surface lightly dusted but
no seriously I love snow so the teaser
gets me shush you every time the this
the trailer gets me because I get the
chills I'm like oh there's going to be
more Lara more Lara Croft's always good
as far as I'm plus it gives a real
indication of tomb raiding yes true no
hands and that's the thing that I get
the most from that it's like you know if
we're gonna if were we've now rebooted
we've now rebooted a character you know
a world and so on and so now let's get
up there in the snow let's let's it's
Rachel doing some damn tools I'm
thinking forward to it this place looks
pretty pretty I'm gonna be like a Zelda
structure right she goes from dungeon to
dungeon through sort sort of a hub world
of some kind of someone I would be very
good with that family it's been a while
early but I'd be good with it's been a
couple of years to stay as they released
the first reboot of to murder as well so
they could have been working on anything
and moving swiftly on we got a bunch of
games to cover here at Gears of War we
know it is something coming out of there
it sounds like we're likely going to see
some sort of HD re-release of the first
one and probably a new one as well
there's at the rumors I keep ya there
has to be an HD re-release of one of
these I mean we've seen so much
popularity so much support behind HD
re-releases of games that people know
and love and what better time to do that
then before you announce a new sequel
like here's a chance to revisit this
world this game that you loved we know
black tusk is working on something years
related but what's it going to be what
form isn't going to take is it going to
be a brand new intrigue in the gears
franchise I mean no matter what its
gonna be a third-person shooter like I
see them doing the halo sort of halo
combat Evolved Anniversary out this fall
halo up for out next fault like gears HD
remaster out this fall new gears out
next I can't yeah I cannot imagine that
they would not show in New Year's would
you be excited when we would you like
something new set of people or set in
the future or like goes back to the
pendulum Wars because they kept talking
about that during the first three games
yeah the pendulum Wars much were the
wars between humans before the whole
locus that emergence there before
emergence day I think that could be
interesting and have but I but then
again I also kind of like the AC
country you know if of character model
and that kind of balance within the
gears world I really no preference
except I think a whole new set of
characters for sure and reference maybe
if it's past you know referencing the
legendary heroes Marcus scenic statues
guys statue of Tom's wife looking all
weird yeah I think that would be cool
okay great see I'm thinking on top down
surface exclusive oh really comma yeah
how about fable legends then oh how
about the village looking for tonight i
won no I I played some last year at last
year's and three not important i want ya
know it just it didn't capture me at all
it felt like it misses the the purpose
of the world uh you know will in the
sense that there was no world building
whatsoever that I really experience it
just seemed like hey people like this
this co-op thing that the kids are doing
so maybe we should get in on that wears
a bride he do we have to do it Oh fable
you know what other IP Microsoft have
crack down oh you ain't about you
looking forward to new crackdown that
feels to me like you have three games of
like the early xbox 360 Roxanne was a
real like oh you can do this in games oh
it's just a game where I climb buildings
and collect orbs and then kind of do
missions every once in a while and the
interesting thing is that we saw a tech
demo which was purportedly for crackdown
which showed you know huge building
being demolished like is that something
that they're going to introduce into the
crackdown universe are we going to see
huge destructible building environment
so that kind of it I that seems like a
logical extension of superheroes in a
huge open city i think that i would be
really excited about crackdown if they
somehow managed to like you said Danny
recapture the thrill of crackdown which
was just leaping around and grabbing
these orbs which is so much you know
like based on just the movement powers
of a superpower team and of course we've
had tons of games that have done that
since so I don't know how exactly you do
that without some different some tricky
locomotion stuff or whatnot but I i
would like to recapture that kind of joy
of exploration and you need that extra
stuff i mean because the original
crackdown was kind of bear just by any
any standard and then crackdown two was
just like oh it's more of that so you
really you need something extra you need
some kind of push i had a lot of
microsoft leaning on that
I peas a new one though that they've
been turning for a couple of years
quantum break what are you looking
forward to in relationship Justin so
who's the developer Rihanna this is
remedies this is the max payne crash sir
ian max payne just it had a great story
like that that was one of the things
that I enjoyed the most about it like
you don't see a lot of those more games
and even though I like I haven't seen a
lot of this like it seems like they're
creating a really interesting world and
no matter what that team creates worlds
that I want to explore which is the most
important part of a game and when they
first showed this off to seem to be a
lot of mortgage colors like cross-media
nonsense happening with a television
show it seems like they've rail that
back quite a lot they haven't really
mentioned the television show except to
say that it's still in development and
now with the delay of this till next
year I it would be weird to me for them
to jump because they showed this was one
a three showing then they showed another
section of just like actual gameplay it
would be weird for me if they didn't at
least tease or so some imagery from the
TV production yeah at least give us some
sort of implication or idea of what that
is and let's run through a couple more
games here that we may or may not hear
out before we get into the juicy
hardware stuff as scalebound anyone in a
bad way to use that last year that is
the one that we're kind of reminds me of
dragon's dogma yeah if it was it for
this one platinum games had a pretty
good record of the past couple years
they do great action game like just big
sentences that'll it'll look really fun
it'll look really good but at
Battletoads I owe any takers going once
uh this could be awesome it's like if
it's a project smart kind of thing like
I'm gonna be ridiculously disappointed
the right just like conquer you get
plays conquer in a world that he doesn't
exist in and doesn't make any sense
Battletoads but I don't know what would
make sense like maybe even just an HD
remake like that I just want this
youtube video called kung fury which was
just like in the top is like extremities
like basically kicked karate fighting a
arcade machine that just keeps flipping
the bird like if battletoads goes like
totally over the top just that kind of
90s or whatever cartoon hero thing and
like really this sort of skewers that or
parodies that then I'm interested and
live action another game that was that
teaser
the same time as scale band was phantom
dust at dark side games have said that
they're off the project on that and but
it doesn't we haven't said like
confirmation of Microsoft that it's
cancelled or anything so we don't think
it's cancelled we saw the pro their work
in progress we saw what a game that they
put together and not something that
Microsoft was looking forward to or not
what they expected other project so it
doesn't sound like it's cancelled it
sounds like maybe they're shifting
developers they don't want to get rid of
it we might see I actually wouldn't be
surprised if we don't hear anything
about it at this e3 they just they're
gonna sit on it and wait till later a
bunch of games coming I have to talk
about from Microsoft we can talk about
four to six for a while but we won't
because it's just gonna be the sixth 40
game so let's talk about okay I like
driving aids but you know let's let's
move on and let's talk about harder a
little bit there was that leaked last
week Mary was reporting on on GS news
all about the controller hey Justin
what's the latest on that if microsoft
said whether or not that's that's true
or false they do not comment on rumors
and speculation but they look forward to
as tall is watching their e3 preference
conference right it would not be outside
the realm of possibility i mean the most
interesting it's not super exciting but
i mean finally have a good controller
where you don't have to have an adapter
for your headset yeah that'd be nice
like you just use a regular headset
that's it yes of course is nice i'm so
glad that that's actually the thing
they're doing but it's also just another
jab in the ribs of like hey remember
when you pay for that extra thing could
be made are playing not do all the
things it should friggin do yeah ah by
this one idiot it's part of this sort of
add this two year long scale backing and
another thing we're going to look
forward to is that they're going to this
whole Windows 10 integration stuff that
they've been pushing across there so
hard ware Board is being reined back as
well so we're going to see a new UI do
you think yeah that's one of the more
exciting things is that Windows late as
weird as this Windows 10 feels like it
could be a really good OS it feels like
they're treating this the way that they
should have been treating windows for
the past couple years it's going to be
something that's open it's going to be
across all of your devices and something
that integrates with Xbox they have
they've been very cagey about exactly
how this is going to work but their
dream like their their vision for this
is not only will you be able to play
xbox games on your PC eventually be able
to play any PC games that you have
through their onto your Xbox and that'll
work in tandem in in some way like that
that's actually really cool I think
that's the splash they need to make
Tech was at the show is talking about
that stuff I mean they might introduce
you know they have the new controller
they might introduce a new console form
factor who knows no new UI new
controller why not just new school is
about in there or something you know we
saw Sony just a rumor leaked out that
they're going terabyte on their built-in
models but yeah that that connectivity
that kind of streaming you know sort of
that game streaming has been a big story
the past couple threes yeah you know
with with Sony's efforts to cross play
and all that stuff i think that
microsoft needs to get in that game and
show not just talk about it but show
some concrete stuff yes just this
talking about sounds really exciting
like the lego employed my pc games on
the xbox one that's 10 more perfectly
all that sounds great but look I've been
there I have a surface I had windows
phones I have an xbox 360 on Xbox one I
was in this ecosystem no no I mean the
thing is like I don't get excited at
this point for a 0 an interface that
goes across all of these devices I
already have that I already have that
and it's awful it didn't work with the
PSP either with their cross yes Zoe I'm
okay if they if they have you know some
similar UI elements but otherwise keep
that stuff all separate like inner
interaction yes that's good don't know
anybody you know get on microsoft office
and get some word maybe six Allah they
like in between you're playing crackdown
to the clippy pops up in the corner ask
you want this looks like an email it's
just so kind of like half-hearted all
through like the windows 8 yeah a system
that I don't know that I get excited
about a UI across platforms anymore I
just don't know that's kind of a
Microsoft in a nutshell we've got a lot
of exciting stuff but nobody really
trusts if they can pull it off so I
guess we'll see in two weeks time as
tuesday I v3 will be showing off the
conference live on gamespot com it's at
nine-thirty a.m. pacific time so make
sure you to come in tune in to the site
then to watch it and watch all of the
information leaked ash by the good
people of microsoft hopefully stuff that
they'll actually stick to this time live
in front of us and we love all our news
posts and reactions to it on the site as
well
you